move over fad Thor everybody's favorite
electric Asgardian just got a new less
fat Shamy moniker in advance of the
digital and blu-ray release of Avengers
endgame Marvel Studios released an
extensive list of the special features
awaiting home viewers and one of those
features is entitled the creation of bro
Thor which is a slightly more charitable
nickname it's just the latest
development and the ongoing saga of well
we suppose we're calling him bro Thor
now although we were always partial to
Tony Stark's christening of the Thunder
God as Lebowski
nobody calls me Lebowski you got the
wrong guy I'm the dude man in case you
somehow weren't aware of the uproar over
the characters portly new physique and
endgame allow us to recap the madness
for you in the film's first act Thor out
of sheer rage and frustration on
ceremoniously decapitated vanos after
the Avengers and Captain Marvel tracked
the mad Titan down to his farm planet it
turned out that famis had essentially
set the Infinity stones to self-destruct
after using them to complete his mission
of wiping out half of all life in the
universe without the stones the Avengers
had no way to undo what had been done
the filmin jumped forward five years a
period during which our heroes had
adjusted to post decimation life in a
variety of ways Natasha Romanoff
desperately struggled to keep all of
Earth's defenders on the same page in
the hope of averting another catastrophe
Bruce Banner found a way to retain his
smarts and personality after hulking out
18 months in the gamma lab I put the
brains and the Brawn together and now
they give me best of both worlds Tony
Stark got married and had a precocious
daughter who loved him 3,000 as for Thor
Wow get it together
well Thor retired to the new Asgard
settlement in Norway to play fortnight
with Korg drink all of the beer he could
possibly get his hands on and put on
just a few pounds recruited by banner
and rocket to take part in the Avengers
audacious plan to travel back to various
periods in time to secure the Infinity
stones before Thanos could Odin son came
along only half willingly for a good
portion of the film especially during
his encounter with his mother Frigga
during a jaunt back to Asgard into
13 it was obvious that his physical
changes were a result of a deep
depression at a crucial moment he had
failed his friends and the planet he had
sworn to protect by way of not going
forth a noses head an oversight which
gave the mad Titan the opportunity to
snap his big purple fingers and make the
Avengers worst fear a reality now we
should mention that during endgame a few
tasteless jokes were lobbed Thor's way
these jokes provoked the ire of a
sizable swath of the internet as many
felt that the character is being fat
shamed and that his depression was used
as a device to make him the butt of
simplistic gags still others though read
the situation a bit differently sure
stark had a few snarky things to say
about Thor's round waistline we submit
that this is because he was Tony Stark
and it would have been completely out of
character for him not to love a few
singers at his friend further Hemsworth
gave an absolutely brilliant performance
which managed to hit comedic notes while
being a completely relatable
illustration of the realities of
depression and don't even get us started
on the fact that despite sinking to his
lowest point he was still worthy of
wielding his beloved Mjolnir we're not
crying you're crying screenwriters
Christopher Markus and Stephen McFeely
have even stated that it was their
intention to use Thor's fragile mental
state to humanize the Asgardian to a
degree and in our humble opinion they
pulled that off smashingly well to no
one's surprise it seems that Marvel
Studios must have caught wind of the
whole brouhaha and made the
understandable decision that the fat
descriptor just wasn't going to work for
official purposes we think it's a
laudable choice how will the ever
polarized internet respond all we can do
is wait and find out fortunately for
Marvel Studios they make movies that are
beloved by you everybody you know
everybody they know and so on but even
the MCU can't please everybody and we
sincerely doubt that Marvel even feels
pressured to try at this point renaming
the stocky Asgardian bro Thor was a
thoughtful move and one that shows that
the House of Ideas isn't into shaming
anybody except of course for Bros we can
expect an overwhelming wave of
indignation from the online bro
community at
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the MCU are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the belt so you
don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]